hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to kholat part 2 now we
are moving up the mountain and we're not
gonna die like an idiot staring at death
in the face which seems to be a thing
that I want to do really badly but when
there's something interesting happening
I just want to run forward towards it
straight with my arms open like it's so
much fun okay so now we're gonna make
our way quickly through here without
getting stopped by any horrifying
monsters anybody help this is the right
way cuz if it's not I'm gonna be good
okay well it seemed precarious and
lovely oh oh I'm at 10:57 so I'm just a
little bit away from where I need to be
my compass is correct it would just be
over that way let me then we're going
the right way then no not because there
was another path to go out of the cave
that indeed there was were house about
to jump down there that would have been
instant death and I would a start over
again listen to Sean Bean which actually
discovered that is Sean Bean and the
trick in this one is that he's already
dead so he's not going to die in this
one but Sean Bean is the voice actor for
the narrator guy the other guy that was
a participant in all this madness oh no
this isn't Beth is there another way out
of this cave or am i hallucinating okay
never mind oh hello what are you doing
up there okay so I think I just need to
cycle around the mountain because if I'm
tall I'm at ten my brother shouldn't
stand around here oh that's right okay
so I need to go up around that's right
it curves up around got it got it got it
got it got it got it so I do come out
this way I do go up around the doodad
where
okay yes over here I do go around the
doodad and everything is gonna be fine
so long as I keep my ass out of danger
when I see bright flashing lights
for God's sake markiplier run run
markiplier run okay hello you me eight
baby okay
Thomas Mountain great that's
good-looking moon it's good-looking
tweet yeah it was a good looking moon I
hear noises I should keep going man I
gotta admit like they the environment
the ambience in this game is phenomenal
is that gonna fall on my head that looks
like the sort of thing note ok we're
fine looks like the sort of thing that
would have fallen on my head don't you
agree lovely people out there watching
so oh hey I'm I'm gonna sneak up on you
all morning
guess who's behind who now woah that's
that's not that's not normal that's not
normal
how do I get away from that what do we
do about that oh is it coming for me
okay I'm Rob just don't stand still back
porch okay I'm outta here okay okay how
do we get up there can I get up there oh
I'm not doing too well I think my whole
leg is that a skull rock that is goddamn
skull rock I didn't notice the goddamn
South another goddamn skull rock
what were the giant humans living around
here was all this bull and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] Kylie elevated level of
bullcrap okay so oh I get to go in
another cave great exactly what I wanted
to do first let me take a no that's not
cave
that's a nothing well what about this
I'm gonna take in the scenic view since
it's so pretty here but
okay I was at a little bit of a mild
delirium as this where I'm supposed to
go knew I could kind of climb up that
but not all the way up no okay all right
fine so what am I supposed to do is
obviously not a cave that thing oh this
no yes no whoa hey I forgot about the
rustling hello looking in room number 23
oh yeah though sitting might not be the
right word because we are running around
trying to finish up packing anything
else we could need food cans tools
essentially whatever we get our hands on
we want to be sure that we took
everything we could possibly need yeah
we're running out of time sure
damnit where did I put my belt I'm sure
we forgot about something we're almost
ready
we lost the knife we're counting the
money honey we're leaving the room in a
complete mess oh good biggie who moved
it to the train station we're singing
all the songs we know and making up new
ones as well everyone is so excited
finally at around 3:00 a.m. we go to bed
I wonder what is awaiting us when we get
there what will we see how far will we
make it
I hear the rest of the group breathing
peacefully and it's snowing outside
that's a really weird way to write a
journal your narration skills need a
little bit of work oh there's that knife
that you were mentioning I should
probably take that when it comes to at
the real aliens I'm pretty sure that I
wouldn't be able to put up a fight
anyway
so do I is there any way to get up there
Oh down here maybe yes no maybe yes
maybe yes yes absolutely yes is that a
skull great love the decoration I just
drooled great cool let's go up here why
not could be fun maybe I don't know
could be huh all right what awaits me
what awaits me whoa oh hey how's it
going buddy you look good
what awaits me okay this looks
horrifying who is this oh god it's like
that thing from Dragon Age Inquisition
at the at the center of the explodey do
oh I guess I'll just walk into this
giant pair of bones oh look at all these
human skeletons I'm sure this fine
beginning to think less aliens more
horrible demons okay all right I hear a
rustling other oh let me just comment
about this by the pint uh-huh a
makeshift campfire suggested they tried
to I decided to thoroughly search the
area between the tent and the tree line
I discovered the other bodies everything
sounded meters apart the position
indicated the victims attempted to
return to the tent as fast as they could
this could mean that the threat was gone
and the group decided to go back to the
tent or just the opposite
someone or something appeared from the
forest and forced its victims to run at
this point it is difficult to determine
what exactly happened I have collected
small samples from all bodies for
further research at the unit's
laboratory I discussed the situation
with the rest of the rescue team and
afterwards they focused on the visual
inspection of the tent and areas by the
trees and I entered the forest I'm sure
that turned out great for you but you're
not Sean Bean oh hey okay that's going
on I'm gonna get out of here because I
learned that to stay around when des is
hanging above my hat is a bad idea
say look I shouldn't look I should go i
scoped on one leg
resemble oh oh I know where I am I gotta
get out here
I gotta get outta my rat oh I didn't
know I wasn't supposed to run that way I
just want to go towards the bright
lights why is that so wrong why do you
hate me why do you want to kill me so
badly game okay let's try though oh hey
fire eyes you're looking pretty dad I'm
out of here okay but have never done
inevitable running running running this
is my first time running away cuz I'm
smart now go the correct path alright
look at this I don't look good oh hey
okay cool giant boulders that's fun too
they're gonna fall on my head
save me save me should mean I know you
can't even save yourself it's to woo
here we go oh yeah I jumped over it I
didn't even know that was gonna be a
thing that looks bad
god I keep forgetting you think in a
panic situation I would be able to run
on pure adrenaline but no let me slog
along and catch my breath is that death
well that's death
death is behind me and I'm going
somewhere where am I going
I don't know why I just got there to the
point where I was gonna read that and
then mean I don't know why that note was
not so narrow okay that's death
alright cool saving gonna hide in here
please yes oh [ __ ] what am i doing what
am i doing what am i doing
okay okay I'm not okay oh no okay that's
yeah the dad
yeah okay oh yeah okay that was weird
I guess I'm fine then I knew you
believed in me for some reason and this
was apparently the exact reason so cool
great
I'm alive and oh I was supposed to use
that tent to fat eye job I forgot about
the fast travel system I do
I only realized as soon as I went over
the precipice of where I could not go
back that I needed to go back to that
and use it to fast travel damn it I'm
sorry to dingus
but for you guys it won't really matter
because I'm gonna fast-forward to the
point where I'm back where I should be
or to the next place so BRB nah okay so
actually according to the map this cave
here right in front of me leads through
it whole network of tubes that
eventually gets to where I need to go so
I need to go in the cave making left at
the fork make another far left of the
fork and then continue on to get to the
next area which is over here so that's
what I'm gonna do and you guys heard
back here because apparently I circled
around a little bit because I was
looking for this and I went too far and
I'm just an idiot so we're back into it
this looks Pleasant Oh joyous day are
those mushrooms now they're eyeballs
great okay that's a bad glow that's that
oh well good I'm glad cultists we're
here lighting candles glad this is the
path I need to dig do oh it is more than
a little unsettling around here whoa
okay campfire that was where I was
supposed to go before so I might as well
walking towards it hello I'm an
unsuspecting traveler I'm totally
unarmed I didn't actually want a
response there but any demon or ghost or
alien if they merely graze my skin they
will destroy me and all that I love
don't question my methods this is how I
intimidate them with my dashing good
looks and horrible demeanor terrible
bedside manner can I supposed to go down
or up the interrupt interrupt dinner at
vocab doesn't look like what I was
seeing on my map but then again the map
doesn't give a lot of details I was
trying to take as many left's as I could
I don't even know if I'm there yet do
you think you're significant I think I
do that you will uncover the truth for
everyone to see possibly so you can
point the finger at the monster yeah
that'd be nice first take a look at the
mirror oh my god I can't do that I'm too
handsome
come behind me what the hell is going on
here this doesn't seem good okay I'm at
2072 oh god it's so creepy
all right 20 damn it I must have taken
uh I must have taken a right when it
okay but I can still make it because if
I get to the exit of this when I can
take a left and go up the middle path I
can still get there it's all there just
that good told you that
stop doing that I don't like that are
you running away from something
should I also run away from that thing
Hey look a page I'll just wander in here
that place you were running away from
cool hello oh this is my turn to read
seversk he's a claw city in Tomsk albama
Russia located 15 kilometers northwest
of Tomsk
excuse me I'm reading on them can you
cut it with a guitar solo on the right
bank of the Tom River and is in the
hands of Raza Tom the federal Atomic
Energy Agency I founded in 1949 it was
known as pyaar talk
Taavi town status was granted in 1956 it
comprised several nuclear reactors and
chemical plants for separation in
Richmond and processing reprocessing of
uranium and plutonium the headquarters
of the Russian research unit for natural
phenomena until 1991 called the Soviet
research unit the unit's activities
concern research on occurring natural
disasters in Russia because everything
weird happens in Russia but thankfully
all the Russians have dash cams ooh okay
all right I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay
rich run run where am I going where am I
going we're gonna come from where to go
where the hell is this leave me out okay
here I go
oh god I'm gonna die no please I don't
want to die God God won't do the exact
opposite of that okay I guess we're fine
then okay oh I'm so this is a bad time
to be slow
oh now yeah now now now is good now is
good in your own time
whatever okay so there's the hell was
that
why didn't they is that me whimpering am
i a girl I didn't know I was real my
high-pitched boy I have no idea what I
am I think I saw another one of those
things over here I thought I would have
been out of here by now
oh is that someone in here oh okay oh
why can't I see you them whoa I don't I
know where they are
is that me why bring her what I hear Oh
Rosalie okay that sounds good know what
I'm here by argument gimme gimme Oh
gimme
okay that wasn't actually a thing
apparently so oh is that me you
whimpering and I'm I'm calm now could
have sworn that I heard a whistle rustle
I do here I do hear a rustling hi well
Russ Lee Russell Crowe Damon it sounds
like it's coming from the altar but it
wouldn't let me pick it up before I have
no idea where I am
I might come back for that cuz I just
want to kind of get a bearing on where I
am because that cave seemed to be filled
with death godsend destruction I don't
want that okay so there's a campfire
obviously that's a good way to go so
this is the path on the map I believe is
just out of this I believe I'm right
here so if I follow this and try to
follow the middle oh wait I was where'd
that come from or am i right here where
am I no I don't mm all right
no I really don't know where I am okay
all right it's great you know do a thing
okay so if I was popping out of there I
have a path to the west maybe that was
her I was supposed to be maybe I was
already in there maybe that's what that
was maybe oh maybe that was actually in
there because if there's a path bleeding
east and west the only place where that
I pop out of a cave and there's paths
leading both east and west is here maybe
that was it
do I gotta go back in there we gotta go
back oh did I die left the place where I
could go back oh I'm such an idiot
ah I don't know what I'm doing I've not
a damn clue what I'm supposed to do it
any fact this is a camp I'm gonna go
with again okay I'm gonna go to the camp
I'm gonna go to the camp I'm gonna go to
the camp I'm gonna go to the cam cam cam
cam cam be camp again goody goody goody
goody okay so where is this on the map
this is right I knew it I was right
I was riggidy right okay so I need to go
back in there I don't
Oana but I need to yes oh crap do I have
to go the long way around because ah
okay so either way I'm gonna do that in
another episode thank you everybody so
much for watching I really hope you're
enjoying this because it's really
creative mister here that I don't know
what's going on and there's Sean Bean in
it totally awesome
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
there's much worse this is a lot work